welcome to the NewsHour we're beginning
Sudan where time is running out for a
ceasefire to be renewed a 72-hour truce
comes to an end at midnight local time
now those who remain in the capital
Khartoum have to contend with looting as
the prices of basic Goods have sold
Traders have complained to police
they're not doing enough to protect
their property well beyond the capital
the conflict has worsened ethnic
tensions in the western region of Darfur
fighting between the Army and the rapid
support forces rages for a second day in
Janina the capital of Westar for the UN
is reporting killings looting and arson
evacuees continue to stream out of the
country hundreds have gathered in Port
Sudan waiting to leave
we just want a solution to this problem
there are a lot of us here help us find
a solution to our situation we just want
to get away from this war we were living
in Khartoum the situation there is
extremely bad so bad thank God we
managed to get out we want to leave
safely and go to Jeddah or Syria we just
want to get out of Sudan
all laboring countries are also seeing
an influx of people tens of thousands
have fled to places like Chad and Egypt
we have correspondence across the region
Malcolm Webb is at Djibouti airport for
us where hundreds of people have arrived
after fleeing Sudan but first let's talk
to Heber Morgan who's in the Sudanese
capital and of course hibber news that
we're focusing on at the moment is about
security uh the situation there this
whole issue about looting uh what what
is happening right now as far as you
know
well for many people what's happening is
that they're not able to leave their
homes especially after sunset here in
the capital Khartoum and this all
started when the break-in when there was
a break-in in
uhuda prison in umdurman about six days
ago and thousands of prisoners were set
free now both sides the rapid support
forces and the Sudanese Army accuse each
other of being behind that prison break
and consequent Prison Breaks because all
five prisons in the capital heartum were
broken into and more than 20 000 inmates
have been able to set themselves free
following those break-ins now the
Sudanese Ministry of interior released a
statement saying that the prisons and
prisoners are their responsibility but
that they're not able to provide the
protection to civilians or to be able to
take care of the prisoners and bring
them back to prisons because their
Ministry their main building is being
occupied by the rapid support forces and
that is it making it hard for many
people in addition to the humanitarian
situation that is already unraveling in
the capital cartoon
the crisis is Big the situation is very
tough and internal movements are
difficult we often stand in long queues
to get bread it happened many times
where we get bread but never the amount
that my family needs
the problem now is how to find cash we
need to take our sick people to
hospitals and to remove dead bodies from
the streets we also need food supplies
to go to the people and to be available
in the shops
the damages hit everything the two
parties are fighting each other and we
the people will be the biggest losers
and the most affected you can see the
situation and see what is happening in
front of your eyes
and Heber as we've progressed through
the day there does seem to be this
nervousness as we Edge towards the end
of this 72-hour ceasefire and what could
transpire after that
well yes indeed people are here in the
capital and around the country are
waiting to see if the Army and the rapid
support forces will agree to the 72-hour
ceasefire uh initiative that was
proposed by the original block igad now
that ceasefire also includes the
Sudanese Army sending an Envoy to the
South Sudanese capital of Juba to
negotiate with the rapid support forces
and voice should the rapid support
forces agree to such a deal now the rsf
is yet to respond or agree to another
72-hour uh ceasefire period but people
say that they've looked at the previous
ceasefires they've seen how they've held
and despite the fact that there are some
residential areas where it was common
there was no fighting they say that
there's been artillery strikes in parts
of the capital like umderman and in the
northern part of the capital as one that
continued even this morning with
fighting between the rapid support
forces and the Sudanese Army and heavy
bombardment around the vicinity of the
presidential Palace so people say that
this ceasefire that is about to end did
not hold in many parts of the capital
and they're waiting to see if the next
one will be agreed upon by both sides
and if that unlike the others would
actually hold
Heaven Morgan forest in the Sudanese
Capital thanks Hippa Let's cross over to
Djibouti and to oh pardon me not yet uh
leaving cartoon is difficult and
dangerous uh UK military planes have
flown citizens out from an air base
north of the capital but it can take
several hours to cover 20 kilometers to
Wadi Stena base Saudi Arabia then India
are amongst the countries that have
evacuated people from Port Sudan about
850 kilometers or a 13-hour Drive East
of Khartoum now some are making the
journey North to Egypt that's about a
thousand kilometers from the capital
While others are taking an even longer
route about 1500 kilometers west of the
border with Chad Ebert Idris is in a
village near the Chad Sudan border
children crossed over from Sudan's
therefore area into this part of Chad
the United Nations High Commissioner for
refugees say they have registered more
than 4 000 refugees and could run alone
and there are hundreds and hundreds more
who are yet to be registered and they
hope to accomplish that in the past in
the next few days now what the the
situation here in this particular Camp
is desperate none of the refugees have
any permanent structure over their head
there are no structures no tents and
some of them are virtually living under
trees and they're telling us that the
situation here is desperate a lot of
them say they haven't eaten over the
past few days now
on this particular day the United
Nations and its agencies deployed to
this particular area to see the
situation for itself it brought along
tons and tons of food items to be
distributed to the refugees and let me
show you in particular what's there for
for them now these are sacks of grains
rice as well as oil that will be
distributed to the refugees all across
this particular region what is not clear
is what happens to the other refugees
who number in their hundreds who are yet
to be registered by the United Nations
uh agencies or relief agencies here now
when we plan the camera to this site
this particular family has just received
its own share of grains we can see it's
like that's wheat and a few uh stuff
like cooking oil palm oil grounded oil
some flour that could help the family
get along until such a time that things
improve in this particular camp now the
United the world food program is telling
Al Jazeera that they have deployed uh a
lot of food items that will cater for
only 20 000 people and the situation
right now in this Camp is that they are
expecting more than 20 000 people in the
days to come the United Nations is
projected between 120 000 to up to 200
000 people crossing from Sudan into this
part of child which means that the
United Nations and its agencies and
other relief agencies need to step step
up their act in order to cater for these
refugees
have an address there while we're joined
Now by Malcolm Webb who's live for us
now at Djibouti airport and Malcolm
there's been a steady stream of planes
coming and going so who's managed to
arrive at the airport and where are they
leaving for
or the U.S France Germany are among the
countries that have been evacuating
their diplomats and some citizens
through djibouti's International Airport
and through the neighboring military Air
Base but just in the last few minutes
we've seen a Canadian aircraft land
Canadian military aircraft going to
stand aside we can take a look uh we
can't tell immediately who it was that
was getting off it but it's one of
several aircraft that we've seen coming
and going uh over the last few hours
including a Turkish military aircraft
further down the tarmac as a Japanese
civilian aircraft which is expected to
take I think the last of the Japanese
citizens have been evacuated from here
back home to Japan in the coming hours
we understand that there are dozens or
possibly a few hundred people here
within the the military base who are
waiting for those transport connections
to take them back to their home
countries we spoke to some immigration
officers here just a short while ago who
said about 2 800 people so far have been
brought here under these air evacuation
programs and that they are ongoing and
that more people are expected with so
many people arriving at the airport
Malcolm one can only assume at the
moment hearing about what's going on
across Sudan about how difficult the
journey must be to actually get to
Djibouti
business
well it's uh the people who are arriving
here have been brought in military
aircraft uh in these air evacuation
operations which have been organized by
their governments and so there's
aircraft are landing wherever and
whenever they safely can in or around
Khartoum or in other parts of the
country and then it's about a two to
three hour flight from from Khartoum to
here uh We've haven't seen with military
aircraft from several different
countries I would mentioned but it's
it's just uh this is a relatively
fortunate a few hundreds of people that
are benefiting from this air evacuation
program initially just diplomats and
citizens but of course the vast majority
of people who are trying to flee Sudan
Sudanese or foreigners are trying to do
so by land to the borders with
neighboring countries as we just saw in
Amazon's report many of them struggling
in in quite difficult condition
Malcolm Webb there for us at your booty
airport thanks so much Malcolm
well many students have gathered at the
border crossing with Egypt at the arkhan
Crossing families have been spending
nights outside in the desert waiting to
be let through some say that they've
been there for days Sudan's doctors
Syndicate has appealed to the red
crescent to help those stranded saying
they don't have access to basic health
services
well many markets in Sudan's capital
have been destroyed and unexploded
ammunition poses a danger to those
who've remained behind Al jazeera's
Ahmed Fidel is in the northern part of
the capital with more
um
this part of the main fruit and
vegetable market was the scene of
violent fighting between the Sudanese
Army and the rapid support forces on
Saturday and as you can see the damage
is evident this truck was carrying
ammunition and it exploded during the
confrontation the shrapnel flew
everywhere the biggest danger now is
that not all ammunition has exploded
this presents a threat to pedestrians
and cars bearing in mind that some
Traders and customers are returning to
the market the ammunition is scattered
around this area these Munitions could
explode at any time due to the high day
temperatures or if cars run over them or
people step on them these buildings were
police officers used to live as well as
the market have been severely damaged
and the explosions and the fighting
which is considered some of the most
violent in this area given the situation
authorities need to intervene quickly
and bring in teams to dispose of the
explosive ordinance safety because
people have started using this road
again
and her family are still in Khartoum she
says that they had to move within the
city to escape the worst of the fighting
we had discussions and flights for three
days
um
the responsibility because we were
moving in a family so if anyone got hurt
then the person who actually suggested
to move we feel the guilt and if you
don't have relatives somewhere else it's
impossible to find an apartment even if
you found one it's very expensive and
people were coming out of Ramadan and
and they did not actually get the the
payment for the new mouse because it was
not even the end of the month yet
no banks because it happened on Saturday
so no one have enough cash on them and
the the gasoline and the petrol problem
was huge most of the cars ran out of
Petrol in the middle of the way so
people had to either leave them in the
middle of the way or try to find some
gasoline nearby and buy it with a very
high expensive prices
Let's cross over to our correspondent
Ahmed Idris who's on the border between
Sudan and Chad with the very latest
obviously a very difficult situation
Emmett for those arriving from Sudan
Where You Are
yeah certainly it's a difficult
situation for hundreds and hundreds of
refugees who are yet to be registered by
the United Nations High Commissioner for
refugees another International donor
agencies we just at a village not far
away from
um kuffron where it is a major
distribution center for the world food
program another eight agencies we
realize that dozens of people who have
fled the situation in Sudan and I camped
out here out in the open in makeshift
structures have not been registered and
therefore couldn't access some of the
aid being delivered to refugees who fled
the crisis in Sudan now basically the
situation is such that the United
Nations has only organized or rather
budgeted for at least 20 000 people uh
in terms of Food Supplies or food
assistance however with the current
situation it looks like the agencies
here the United Nations agencies as well
as other donor organizations that like
the wall food program don't have enough
to feed the expected number of people
who are crossing over from Sudan and
into child earlier this morning today
there were reports of skirmishes across
the border not at 35 kilometers from the
town of Garrison town of adre where
people or locals who are reporting here
in gunfire and explosions not far away
in the town of Yanina which is of course
being contested by both parties in the
conflict in Sudan initial reports
indicate that it is as Skirmish between
rival ethnic factions but there are
reports that indicate that there is more
to it than just ethnic clashes there as
you say I mean there are many hundreds
of people arriving Where You Are by the
hour just give us an idea of the journey
that you've had to make from the last
urban area to where you are now how long
that Journey takes because that's an
indication of how long the aid is going
to take if the UN can actually get it to
the locations on the border where they
need it most
basically to travel from the capital in
Jamaica to uh you look you're looking at
probably 900 kilometers so eight
delivery will have to be by fair and
unfortunately as it is now there are
reports of shortage of Aviation fuels so
the flights are irregular so that means
that definitely uh the aid is being
delivered in trickles and probably at a
staggered Pace uh right now when the aid
reaches a beche it has when the aid
reaches a battery it has to come on to
uh places like China from fasana you
drive to Andre which is the biggest
border border town in this location and
then you have to come forward at least
closer to the Border uh to places like
uh kofron which is uh just a few
kilometers or 100 100 hundreds of
kilometers just a few kilometers
actually hundreds of meters away from
the Sudanese but while we're standing
now we can see the uh telecommunication
patients mass in Sudan which is not far
from here by the way and kuffron is just
behind these uh structures over there so
it means these eight have to be
delivered and they have to cross rivers
the rainy season has just started and I
if the rains uh sort of pour out in a
huge amount that will delay a journey
that is supposed to take like say for
example one or two hours or it will take
probably seven days for Aid to be
delivered to this particular location so
it would people are really really
desperate and believe me uh what is
happening right here many people we're
talking about hundreds of people who are
living out in the open under two shades
and makes you structures like the ones
you see behind me right here Emma good
to get an update from you there on the
Sudan Chad boarded Emmett address for us
there thank you
uh we're joined by David chin the former
U.S diplomata a former U.S Diplomat with
Decades of experience in Africa he's a
professor of international relations at
George Washington University and joins
me now via Skype from Washington DC Mr
Shin good to have you with us live on Al
Jazeera uh we really just to get to the
politics here we've heard that the
warring sides in the Sudanese conflict
say this is a domestic problem that
they'll sort it out themselves yet they
have been speaking to International
stakeholders including the US who
secured this recent ceasefire and a
window of opportunity for evacuations
it's a step in the right direction but
it's nothing permanent is it
no it's not permanent at all and the
immediate goal is to extend the
ceasefire which may happen although
there have already been violations of
the cease fire but that's not the answer
the the answer is to bring this to a
permanent close and the goal of the
international most of the International
Community is to eventually transition to
a civilian government that's basically
what set off this conflict to begin with
and there's now very little likelihood
of moving to a civilian government
anytime in the foreseeable future and of
course with the mistrust between these
two well-armed warring sides you have an
International Community it seems that
can do very little yes there are certain
countries that have an Avenue of
conversation to one side or the other we
know Egypt is is in touch with burhan
the UAE is perhaps in touch with the rsf
how do you read the situation about
where the middle ground and who these
people who these two sides might want to
talk to if they want to talk to anybody
at all
well that's the the question whether
they want to talk to anyone at all and
they may not want to talk to anyone so
that means that uh those uh countries
and organizations that have an interest
in ending this problem need to try to
talk to them and to leverage uh whatever
they can in order to get their attention
and to get them to change course I would
argue that no single country no single
organization has enough leverage to
convince either side to bring this to a
halt but collectively I think the
International Community could have a an
enormous impact on them if it could
agree upon a common approach what sort
of sign should we be looking for now in
terms of any ceasefire that could be
negotiated in South Sudan the military
leader and the Army leader should I say
berhan is is willing to apparently
according to sources say yeah he's
willing for another 72-hour ceasefire
the rsf uh are still an unknown quantity
at this moment in time what would you
want to see in terms of movement what
are you expecting to see as a diplomat
uh one I'd want to see more sincerity
from both of these military leaders than
I have seen so far they uh they've made
uh grandiose promises in the past that
both have said that they were willing to
transition to a civilian government but
there's a big question whether they have
ever been sincere about that and they
need to take some tangible steps in that
direction to show their sincerity and I
haven't seen that of late so we saw it
two years ago when there was uh for a
period of time a combination military
civilian government and things looked
helpful back then but that came to an
abrupt end when the military seized
power two years ago and basically a
military coup and since then we haven't
really seen any uh sincere willingness
by either side to move towards the
civilian government in your opinion how
important is igad the intergovernmental
Authority on development it consists of
Ethiopia Kenya Somalia Djibouti Uganda
Eritrea that all surround Sudan they are
all neighbors they all work together on
economic and environmental projects
together but they also have a political
connection too and I wonder in that
grouping do you think there is anybody
that has you might say some sway some
power to actually get these sides to
talk to them foreign
probably not it's important to bring the
intergovernmental Authority and
development countries into this
discussion there should be a key part of
it they they can bring moral situation
uh into the discussion that they don't
have much tangible Leverage The Leverage
comes from those uh countries and
organizations that have some economic
clout in Sudan now that would mean or or
direct military Cloud that would mean
countries like the United Arab Emirates
um Egypt
the Russian Wagner Group which is
closely aligned with the rapid support
forces the international monetary fund
the World Bank
those countries that hold the debt of
Sudan all of these countries
collectively need to come together and
and put pressure on both sides bring
this to a hall it'll be interesting to
see what does happen in the next few
hours very important next year as David
chin thanks so much for joining us from
Washington DC thank you
thank you